hi I'm Neil Patrick Harris and this is
the wired autocomplete interview
I assume there would be titles
I Google myself
a lot of times throughout the day
[Music]
so the Google is what Neil Patrick
Harris like what Neil Patrick Harris or
like what Neil Patrick Harris I don't
know what Google thinks the inflections
are but let's see what is Neil Patrick
Harris doing these days a lot what am I
doing these days I was just in London
filming a uh episode of a special for
Doctor Who or I play someone I'm not
allowed to talk about
and I had to have a posh British accent
or did I and now I'm hanging out with my
kids in our place in East Hampton with
my husband called Funhouse Farm fixing
things super gluing things and learning
how hand tools work what was Neil
Patrick Harris first movie Clara's heart
it was a Whoopi Goldberg film and I
played sort of a very waspy kid that she
was the housekeeper to and it was based
on a novel by the same name and it was
amazing to have your first movie be
opposite Whoopi Goldberg who is as cool
in real life as you would think by
watching her be cool in her her on
camera Persona what episode did Neil
Patrick Harris direct I directed an
episode of How I Met Your Mother and it
was incredibly exciting I got to film a
parody as if I was doing an SNL short
you know that kind of vibe and I got to
yell at the cast which I think was most
fun amazing job Allison this time I'm
just try to care I'm going to be a good
director someday what did Neil Patrick
Harris
win a Tony for I want a Tony for playing
Hedwig in the Revival on Broadway of
Hedwig and the Angry Inch sort of punk
rock show stomped around like Mick
Jagger lived my life lost 21 pounds
got a yeast infection on my vocal cord
and thanks for that they gave me a
trophy maybe because since I posted the
awards before I just pay people to
change the names in the envelopes what
game
did Neil Patrick Harris invent well I've
done a couple games boxed games one's
called Amazed quick word puzzles it's
the board that you're playing can fold
and unfold and refold in all sorts of
different ways so the board itself is
always different I've also after that
did a game called box one that's dope
it's a party game for one person box one
too many of these games require too many
people to play what if you're by
yourself it's not what you think it is
when you start playing it it's a bit
escape the roomy
something's in my eye
uh and I can't say more about it because
then it screws up the experience we're
working on box two right now what will
it be wouldn't you like to know it'll at
least be more expensive
probably won't actually more questions
bring them on watch this magic trick
is Neil Patrick Harris
the new Doctor Who no I'm not the new
Doctor Who is a man named
who's amazing he's on a show called sex
education right now and I think his
doctor is going to be super dope is Neil
Patrick Harris really a magician
you'd be the judge watch this
see this in my hand watch closely
it's gone
my love for magic runs deep I used I
grew up in a small town in New Mexico
and in a larger town called Albuquerque
there was a magic shop I'd buy as many
little pack of Tricks as I could all the
stuff that you need and all the words
that you need to say patter and the ex
the secret is in there I heard about
this thing called The Magic Castle which
was a private club in Los Angeles but
you couldn't go unless you were a
magician and you couldn't get in unless
you knew the secret password well my
father who is an attorney his secretary
got to go to the Magic Castle and she
refused to tell me and so I became a
junior member I auditioned when I was in
Los Angeles playing a doctor person and
I know the secret password now I'm not
gonna tell you because you have to
figure it out on your own then I became
a regular member then I became uh I was
on the board of directors and then I
became the president of the place
changed stuff around new valet new food
and
um it's doing better than ever so if you
can get a way into the Magic Castle you
too can have that same experience is
Neil Patrick Harris married well what do
you think sucker you see this thing I am
married to a youngish man David Michael
birchka he's an actor he's won the Fred
Astaire award for his dancing skills on
Broadway he's very critical of me
no it's not David's great we've been
married for eight years but together for
18. is Neil Patrick Harris friends with
Jason Siegel well let's define friends
is anyone friends with Jason Siegel
really is Jonah Hill friends with Jason
Siegel yeah he's a really lovely guy
he's adorable super humble when you meet
him he'll be like oh hey wow that's so
nice you say that I really appreciate
you so much and he knows all the lyrics
to Les Miserables and we would sing
Javert and Valjean Duets together all
the time so friend for life was Neil
Patrick Harris
in Starship Troopers fun fact I wasn't
it was the kid from Malcolm in the
Middle no that's not true I was in
Starship Troopers Paul verhoven film
I played Carl Jenkins and I get to touch
big giant um evil bugs that look very
vaginal and uh say that they're
frightened Starship Troopers I only
recommend the first one
sorry
does Neil Patrick Harris like suits love
suits let's talk about suits buy a
medium
priced suit not to spend too much money
on it spend a little extra money getting
your suit tailored dude well tailored
suit get a black one and maybe a blue or
brown one you could be the nicely
dressed person at any event always
recommend the suit does Neil Patrick
Harris tap dance nope never taken a
dance lesson in my life which is a
problem because I have imposter syndrome
they call me a song and dance man I've
never taken a dance class in my life
I've danced a lot I can make I can move
a bit but I I'm often surrounded by like
Broadway dancers who are really really
good at what they do and I just feel
inept in every way can't tap dance would
like to learn you have to have loose
ankles I hear does Neil Patrick Harris
have the vfd tattoo
do I
and flexibility look at that bad boy vfd
tattoo is from series unfortunate the
vfd tattoos from Series of Unfortunate
Events Count Olaf had the same tattoo in
like Midway through season one I thought
well I should get that tattoo because
there's only been a few people who will
ever have played Count Olaf and I don't
think Jim Carrey is that committed as an
actor a v an f and a d that only the
people who watch the whole show know
what it stands for does Neil Patrick
Harris watch Cobra Kai
okay
I haven't seen it yet I have too many
shows like that I am just now watching
the crown by the way that Claire Foy
she's gonna go places she's amazing but
I haven't when am I gonna watch season
one at Cobra Kai it's already now
there's like season seven of Cobra Kai
does Neil Patrick
Harry
s
sing in Glee I sang a single song leave
on
with Matthew Morrison in an episode that
was directed by Joss Whedon and I wanted
an Emmy Award for it it was not because
I was the best person of the season in
guest actor in a thing category it was
because I was on the Glee train don't
regret it
sorry
how rich what oh how is Neil Patrick
Harris
awesome thanks for asking
how old was Neil Patrick Harris Doogie
Howser strange sentence structure Google
I expect more from you with the AI I did
the pilot of that show when I was 15.
I did the first season of that show when
I was turning 16
and it ran for four years so let me do
the math
carry the one
16 to 24. how many books
has Neil Patrick Harris written I've
written four volumes of the magic Misfit
series can't recommend it enough super
good maybe uh an animated series soon
not dropping bombs but you know fingers
crossed happening I also wrote an
autobiography the choose your own
autobiography of Neil Patrick Harris
it's kind of like a choose on adventure
where some of the stories are fake some
of them are super heartfelt some super
gay and some super funny and so if you
get bored with the one you just like it
says if you want to hear more about
Elton John go to page 164. how how many
languages does Neil Patrick Harris oh
speak fluently one
English
Francais maybe a little bit of Italiano
one and one tenth
what was Neil Patrick Harris for
Halloween what aren't I for Halloween I
was always when I was young obsessed
with Tom savini and all the crazy makeup
stuff Prosthetics love the gore I love
the fake blood I love Halloween I love a
safe scare I'm a big fan of haunted
houses in that way I love being scared
but knowing that they can't touch me and
that's probably why I had kids to dress
them up in funny costumes what happens
to Neil Patrick Harris in Gone Girl
spoilers in Gone Girl
I Fall In Love
with a woman
and maybe keep her a little captive and
it does not end well what kind of dog
does Neil Patrick Harris think he is oh
have better
I have three dogs
our family does one is a rescue
mom just make name Gidget she's the
oldest now then there's another rescue
named Spike he's about this big and he
looks a little bit like a seal and he
loves to stand on my shoulders and let
me kiss underneath his belly
and a third dog a golden retriever that
Santa brought the children named Ella my
father came up with her middle name
which is menopee so her full name is
LMNOP you're welcome
what episode was Neil Patrick Harris on
Beat
Bobby Flay I think I've done Beat Bobby
Flay twice it's a great gig you don't
have to memorize any lines sit there
like you like you're an expert you get
to say snarky things about food that you
don't like and you get to eat the
delicious food all day could I beat
Bobby Flay in the show I'm from New
Mexico so I know my way around like a
burrito but I feel like Bobby Flay she
knows his way around it's the Mexican
food too so no I couldn't beat Bobby
Flay at anything my husband's good my
husband's Bolognese
is stupid delicious so I would say that
maybe David's Bolognese could top a
Bobby Flay but that's personal
preference
remarkably quiet that one thank you so
much wired audience for uh suffering
through all of that it was fun for me
keep watching check me out on the
uncoupled where I'm
in flagrante delecto and also sign up
for wondercade my Weekly Newsletter it's
free and I should never have said yes to
it because every week I have to come up
with cool fun things to talk about okay
bye
three two one
bye